the council is called to order
provisional agenda for this meeting is
threats to International Peace and
security
the agenda is adopted
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I invite the representatives of Belarus
the Democratic People's Republic of
Korea
Eritrea Nicaragua the Syrian Arab
Republic and the belief the bolivarian
Republic of Venezuela to participate in
this meeting
so decided
the security Council will now begin its
consideration of item 2 of the agenda
members of the council have before them
document s struck 2023 struck 212.
the test of a draft resolution submitted
by Belarus China the Democratic People's
Republic of Korea Eritrea Nicaragua the
Russian Federation decision Arab
Republic and the boulevardian Republic
of Venezuela
the council is ready to
okay I'm sorry
I now give the flow to those members of
the council who wish to make statements
before the vote
I give the flow to the representative of
Russian Federation you haven't flown
um
States
exchange between Russian foreign
with differing degrees of absurdity and
reliability
foreign
to the egregious situation regarding
National investigations
[Music]
full International attention
there is no doubt as to the need
and the International Community as a
whole thank you very much
think the representative of Russian
Federation for their statement
the council is ready to proceed to the
vote on the draft resolution before it
I shall put the draft resolution to the
vote now
will those in favor of the draft
resolution contained in document s
struck 2023 struck 212. please raise
their hand
I thank you
those against
abstentions
thank you
the result of what of the Voting is the
is as follow
three votes in favor
zero fourths against
12th abstention
the draft resolution has not been
adopted
having failed to obtain the required
number of votes
I now give the flow to those members of
the council who wish to make statements
after the vote
I give the flow to the representative of
United States you have the philosophy
thank you Mr President
let me Begin by reiterating our deep
concern regarding the sabotage that took
place on the nordstream one in Nordstrom
2 pipelines in September 2022.
the United States categorically refutes
Russia's unfounded allegations leveled
against us in relation to this act of
sabotage
the United States was not involved in
any way
period
as we have said previously the
International Community cannot tolerate
any deliberate actions to damage
critical infrastructure
however
let us be clear on what Russia's draft
resolution was
and what it was not
it was an attempt to discredit the work
of ongoing National investigations and
Prejudice any conclusions they reach
that do not comport to Russia's
predetermined and political narrative
it was not an attempt to seek the truth
the competent National investigations by
Sweden Denmark and Germany are
proceeding in a comprehensive
transparent and impartial manner
as many council members have said they
must first be allowed to conclude
that is why we did not support this
draft resolution and voted to abstain
today
we must ask why
despite having failed to make its case
to the council Russia still chose to
bring this resolution to a vote
it is difficult to accept Russia's
posturing that it only seeks an
impartial independent investigation
let it be clear for the record
that the first draft of Russia's
resolution clearly implicated the United
States
based on mischaracterizations of
statements made by U.S officials
the first draft criticized the
investigations of other U.N member
states
over the course of many rounds of
consultations
Russia failed to provide any credible
new information to justify a U.N
investigation at this time
I repeat
Russia has consistently sought to
advance a political agenda based on
unfounded accusations and predetermined
culpability
Russia's decision to call for a vote on
a resolution that has such little
support should make us all question what
its true intent is
un resources for U.N investigations
should be preserved for scenarios where
States fail or are unable to carry out
genuine impartial investigations
that is not the case today
we cannot allow Russia's continued
spurious allegations to distract this
Council or unnecessarily divert the U.N
scarce resources from other pressing
matters deserving of this council's
attention and resources
if Russia were truly committed to
protecting civilian infrastructure
it would demonstrate this through its
actions
Russia's claim to be concerned over the
sabotage of critical infrastructure
belies the fact that Russia is
relentlessly attacking its neighbor
it is striking cities and towns across
Ukraine
damaging and destroying residential
areas and medical facilities
Russia's attacks against Ukraine's
civilian infrastructure have left
Millions displaced without power and in
need of humanitarian assistance
Russia's calls for accountability today
ring Hollow thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of the United
States for their statement I now give
the float to the representative of Gabon
you have the philosopher
um
these investigations very often
questioning the sovereign
foreign
[Music]
for transparency and Independence thank
you
I thank the representative of Gabon for
their statement and now I give the flow
to the representative of Ghana
thank you Mr President
Ghana considers the preservation of
peace and overarching objective of the
Mandate that underpins the important
work of this Council this has underlined
our overall approach the discussions on
the attacks on the North stream one and
two gas pipelines
Ghana abstain from the votes on the
draft resolution submitted by the
Russian Federation not because we are
against International investigations but
because we recognize that at this stage
there are three ongoing investigations
by competent International authorities
that have committed to a fair and
impartial process to establish the truth
surrounding this deliberate Act of
sabotage
well we have taken note of the
expression of some dissatisfaction with
the conduct of the current investigative
processes our own assessment is that it
may be premature to launch or Advocate
parallel International investigations
under the auspices of the United Nations
which does not have its own capacity for
such investigations
Mr President as a country we use the
intervention during the two earlier
meetings on this matter to urge all the
parties and actors to exercise
restraints and to cooperate in good
faith with the national investigations
currently underway we believe that that
call for restraint is still relevant
today we call on all the parties to
Foster trust and deepen confidence
building by avoiding all unilateral
actions that could potentially undermine
efforts to establish the facts unravel
the truth and pursue the needed
accountability
Mr President we are at the same time
also mindful of the solemn
responsibility conferred by the chapter
on the council in this respect we wish
to make three points which we believe
are necessary to help bring an early
closure to the matter
firstly the ongoing National
investigations need to be expedited they
should be time bound and not open-ended
and should Endeavor to keep the Russian
authorities and operators informed on a
timely basis of all actions and their
cooperation sought as necessary
secondly giving the global interest in
the matter
it is important that this council is
regularly updated on developments
pertaining to the ongoing National
investigations
we welcome in this regard The Joint
letter of 21st February 2023 as well as
that of 24th March 2023 submitted by
Germany Denmark and Sweden and encourage
more of such relevant and positive
updates
lastly we stress the necessity and
importance of upholding the objects of
Security Council resolution 2341 on
protecting critical infrastructure
especially of a transnational kind to
that end while we await the completion
of the national investigations we
believe that as a council we must work
in a constructive manner in finding a
unified voice to strongly deploy the
present attacks in order to send a
strong message to would-be perpetrators
that attacks on similar critical
infrastructure will not be tolerated by
the International Community I thank you
I think
I thank the representative of Ghana for
their statement and I now give the flow
to the representative of Ecuador you
have the flosser
senior president Mr President
related to the gas pipelines
[Music]
recognizes
it Still Remains insufficient
indeed
on the contrary
including energy
investigations congratulations
thank you
I think Ecuador for their statement and
I now give the float to the
representative of Malta you have the
flow Madam president Malta gain
retreated deep concern about the damage
to North stream one and two pipelines
last September and condemns any attack
on critical infrastructure such acts are
dangerous and responsible not least in
the context of a global energy crisis
we listened to the information presented
by the pen hold of this resolution and
others including during the briefing
held on the subject last month
unfortunately until this point the
information presented in support of this
draft lacks credible supporting evidence
furthermore investigations by Denmark
Germany and Sweden are ongoing and it is
important to allow these National
processes to be concluded without
interference
we also welcome the updates provided by
these states last month
Malta has therefore abstained in the
vote of this resolution on the basis
that at this point any investigatory
action by the UN would be premature and
would undermine the Integrity of these
ongoing National investigations which
are being comprehensively undertaken by
the directly affected parties thank you
thank the representative of Malta for
their statement and I give now the flow
to the representative of Switzerland
I thank the representative of
Switzerland and I give now the flow to
the representative of Japan you have
thank you Mr President
since the beginning of the negotiations
our delegation has continuously engaged
in the discussions on the draft
resolution
Japan is deeply concerned about the
incident which happened to the north
stream pipelines and is closely
monitoring the progress of the ongoing
National investigations
Japan abstained from this resolution
because Japan believes that the council
should first allow the national
investigations to be completed and then
based on the results thereof the council
May discussed ways forward as necessary
I thank you Mr President
thanks Japan for their statement and I
give the flow to the representative of
the United Kingdom you have the flu
thank you president
the United Kingdom condemned the act of
sabotage against the north stream
pipelines and we do so again now
we fully support the national
investigations currently being conducted
by Denmark Germany and Sweden and look
forward to their results
we support investigative commissions by
the Secretary General when mandated
however in the context of the ongoing
National investigations we do not think
that it is appropriate to instigate one
in this situation
it has been cleared during negotiations
that Russia is not serious about an
impartial investigation
last month the Russian permanent
representative claimed Russia already
knew with a high degree of certainty who
blew up the pipelines and how
Russia's goal throughout this process
has been to politicize the issue and
Target another council member
this is why the UK
with the overwhelming majority of this
Council
has abstained
finally presidents Russia's apparent
concern for civilian infrastructure is
hard to take seriously in the context of
its Relentless assaults on Ukraine's
civilian infrastructure over the last
year
this cynical aggression must storm
thank you
I think the United Kingdom for the
statement and I give now the flow to the
representative of France
[Music]
expressed its concern after the two
underwater explosions
at North stream on the 27th of September
information available suggests that
these explosions are the result of a
deliberate event to the human origin
these are unprecedented events which
must be subject to in-depth
investigations
today precisely because investigations
are currently underway
seriousness
when Russia is already attributed
responsibilities
and I now give the flow to the
representative of Albany
in the security council meeting on this
issue in February and during the
follow-up consultations we have clearly
expressed our deep concern regarding the
act of sabotage on the pipeline's North
stream one and two in the explosive
exclusive economic zones of Denmark and
Sweden in the Baltic Sea
such acts are unacceptable
we fully support the promptly launched
and ongoing investigations by the
national authorities of Denmark Germany
and Sweden
we are grateful for their work so far
and we look forward to a comprehensive
objective and impartial investigation
we support the UN investigative efforts
whenever they are mandated however at
this moment we don't see any added value
in initiating a parallel investigation
International investigation
any attempts to discredit de-cabilize
over and politicize the ongoing
investigation process including by
accusing deliberately other states based
on prejudices assumptions or convenience
or Reliance on unverified press elements
put artificially together or wrong and
unhelpful they do not have our support
because such efforts will impedes the
path towards the clarification of the
issue
Mr President
infrastructure is a legal obligation for
all states anytime and everywhere
in order menu to choose from
in this case Russia's credibility in
the case
while it is destroying intentionally
methodically and relentlessly the vital
and civil infrastructure in Ukraine with
deadly consequences is at least dubious
and of the most cynical this is why
Albania abstained on the draft
resolution I thank you
I thank Albania for this statement and I
give the flow to China to the
representative of China
foreign
Mr President
in
have not yet reached an agreement
foreign
to the representative of Russian
Federation you have the philosa
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Denmark Germany and Sweden and you can
see that we were they refused to
correspond with us I just like to make
National investigations
it might last for years
it was so unacceptable
predetermined rather
we say
Ukraine but we say that there's no
mention whatsoever of Ukraine in the
residence
and different absurd ideas because there
are facts that are just not acceptable
Washington if the U.S really wanted to
establish the facts
then it would act completely
and everybody had to decide which wanted
to take on what world we wanted one
where the rules are upheld
where and in which case we'd need to
have punishment or a world where that's
not the case of a world where there are
states
where everything is allowed and they
themselves write the rules despite
saying
but they themselves don't bear any
responsibility for the most egregious
acts
that they can just do whatever they want
and get away with it
videos
which means that the council just is not
able to carry out information
because this is unavoidable thank you
very much
I thank the representative of Russian
Federation
and I now give the flow to the
representative of United Arab Emirates
you have
Mr President the UAE unequivocally
condemns the September 2022 sabotage
against the nordstream one and two
pipelines these criminal Acts cause
severe environmental harm and endangered
Global energy security
sabotage against trans-boundary energy
infrastructure Gravely concerns the
International Community
the principles of sovereignty and
international cooperation are vital in
addressing threats to Global energy
security we recognize the importance of
the ongoing National investigations of
Denmark Germany and Sweden and stress
the need for National authorities to
conduct thorough inquiries and we urge
transparency in sharing their findings
with the relevant actors
Global energy security demands sovereign
states collaboration the UAE knows
firsthand the necessity of cooperation
and information sharing during
investigations for this reason we are
encouraged by Denmark's invitation to
the pipeline operator to retrieve an
object possibly related to the sabotage
we hope that this is a signal that
increased cooperation between
investigating countries and stakeholders
will be forthcoming in the near future
Mr President we abstained on the draft
resolution as National investigations
continue and we encourage the expansion
of last week's Cooperative efforts as
well as a clear deadline for the
investigation's conclusions
committed to addressing this issue we
emphasize the global energy security is
vital for every country and reiterate
the Paramount importance of protecting
energy infrastructure thank you
I thank the representative of United
Arab Emirates and I now give the flow to
the representative of Brazil you have
the philosophy
thank you Mr President
Mr President
any proposal by a council member must be
considered in a respectable respectful
and objective manner
Brazil engaged constructively in the
negotiations from the start
and proposed several amendments with the
aim of bridging different positions and
perceptions
and trying to build consensus
Brazil voted in favor of the draft
resolution on the explosions on the
Nordstrom
as many members of this Council
rightfully noted at our meeting on
September 30th this is about a threat to
International Peace and security
preliminary information
provided by the authorities of European
countries indicates that this was an act
of sabotage with possible involvement of
a state actor
six months after the explosions we still
do not know what caused them
the caution with which the issue has
been handled by the authorities of
Denmark Germany and Sweden is
understandable
Brazil vote should not be interpreted as
a criticism of the conduct of the
investigations or a sign of mistrust
but as recognition of the importance of
additional and more comprehensive
efforts on the part of the United
Nations
I'd like to reiterate our understanding
that each proposal in the security
Council must be analyzed on its own
merits
since we considered the explosions in
the Baltic Sea as a threat to
International Peace and security a
commission established by the Secretary
General would be well suited to assist
this Council in its decisions
Mr President
in view of the rejection of The Proposal
Brazil encourages those responsible for
ongoing investigations to share their
conclusions with this Council as soon as
possible
the seriousness of the issue requires a
quick and transparent response to the
concerns of member states I thank you Mr
President
I think Brazil for their statement
the representative of the United States
has asked for the flow to make a further
statement
I give them the flow
thank you Mr President my apologies for
taking the floor but I need to respond
to points that were made by the
representative of the Russian Federation
um
as was mentioned here from the beginning
since the attacks took place Russia has
blamed the United States for carrying
out these attacks
claiming that we are responsible for
having carried them out
uh
with those comments it was very clear
that Russia was not interested in an
impartial investigation he had already
decided uh who was who the guilty
culprit was
Russia was simply playing politics
the three countries that have launched
investigations uh are concerned
about
what is happening to infrastructure
around the world we need to let those
investigations play out
um I think it's a positive sign that
Russia is showing concern about the
threat to critical critical
infrastructure particularly this piece
of critical infrastructure
my hope is that it will show the same
concern about Ukraine's infrastructure
and what's being reigned upon it
thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of the United
States
for their statement
I now
I mean the representative of Russian
Federation has asked for the flow to
make a further statement you have the
flu
foreign
and that was something that he said way
before the pipeline was actually
destroyed how do you understand that I
put to my U.S colleague I think the
representative of Russian Federation for
their statement
may I appeal the members of the council
I think
United States is still oh we
if I may
I give the flow to the representative of
U.S
the United States again thank you Mr
President my apologies for taking the
floor but uh typical the Russian
Playbook is to always uh pose a question
without really having any intent
first and foremost uh I don't read
Seymour hersh's articles uh and frankly
I don't base in the United States
doesn't base its policies or respond
simply to charges by an individual
journalist
let me just say
that the charges that have been made by
Russians
Russian officials
about U.S supposed culpability for
carrying out these attacks
are just flat out wrong
plain and simple
I would just submit to my Russian
colleague that instead of playing
politics with such an important issue
like this
that it deal with the question of
critical infrastructure and
responsibility
and again
I point to the fact that Russia has no
credibility when it comes to this issue
of protecting critical infrastructure
just look what it's doing in Ukraine
so I would just say to my Russian
colleague instead of asking questions
about
the United States and its views toward
critical infrastructure it needs to ask
itself
about what it's doing in Ukraine and
whether that shows responsible behavior
with regard to critical infrastructure
thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of the United
States for this statement and uh
I now Agave the flow to the
representative of Russian Federation for
to make a further statement and then
after this I'm going to close the
meeting
and I did not receive a response to that
particular question that specific
question thank you
yes I think the representative of
Russian Federation for their statements
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers the meeting is
adjourned
[Music]
foreign